Let's say we have a formula like ODD plus ODD equals EVEN.
Now, one of the rules of the way we form numbers is that we don't want to have
a number that starts with 0.
EVEN could be, say, 3435.
That would be a perfectly valid set of digits to fill in for the word EVEN.
It shouldn't be 0405, because we just don't normally write numbers with a leading zero.
I excluded that. How did I do it?
I did a regular expression search for the regular expression slash b,
which matches at a word boundary--b stands for boundary.
Then I'm looking for a zero followed by any digit 0-9.
I'm looking for that within f, and I want that to be not true.
If I took this string here--something plus something equals 0405,
and I did this regular expression search, it's saying find me a word boundary,
a boundary between a letter and/or a digit
and something that's a punctuation or something else,
a word boundary followed by a 0, followed by another digit,
it would say, yes, indeed, that search does succeed.
It succeeds right here. The 0 and the 4 match.
I want that not to succeed, so I would return False.
I would rule out this case where we have a word starting with 0 and 4.
I did that, one, just because it's good form
that normally you don't allow valid numbers to start with a zero,
and also because in Python we could come up with an error because of that.
Here is the problem.
In a Python program, the string 012 corresponds to an integer,
but the integer it corresponds to is not 12. It's 10. Why is that?
Well, it's an old historical accident.
Way back in the 1970s, the C programming language defined it that way,
where they said any number that starts with a 0 is going to be interpreted
as an octal number, which means base 8.
So 012 means one 8, zero 8-squared, and 2 more, so 8 + 2 is 10.
So that would give us the wrong answer if we allowed octal numbers
to sneak in where we were expecting decimal.
It would also give us a possible error.
If we had the string 09 that gives you an error, because 9 is not an octal digit.
To avoid all those problems, I put in this regular expression that says
any time you see a lead zero just rule it out.